[Musique]
dans la comédie musicale my fair lady
il y a beaucoup de costumes et de
couleurs pas seulement pour eliza
doolittle qui passe de la marchande de
violette en guenilles à la femme de la
haute société mais aussi pour les
quelques 80 choristes et danseurs sur
scène soit plus de 300 costumes
[Musique]
pour confectionner tous à la fabrique
opéra fait appel à des professionnels et
à des élèves
halim bourgoin tient le rôle de la mère
du professeur higgins
elle est aussi l'une des trois chef
costumière
on travaille avec quatre établissements
et huit classes en tout deux niveaux
différents il ya des élèves qui sont
assez ap jusqu'au bts donc les élèves
les plus avancés on doit travailler sur
les questions d sonis donc ont bien sûr
participé au dessin
la création de la à z côté coiffure
c'est aussi l'effervescence chignon
bouclettes gomina les têtes à coiffer
son chêne et il y a de quoi faire entre
les choristes les solistes et les
différents changements de scène sur ce
stand l'art il avait l'entraînement de
tous les choristes
à l'intérieur vous avez l'entraînement
des solistes les coiffures donc là ce
sont des chats de du cfa de la chambre
de métiers et de l'artisanat du loiret
qui viennent coiffer donc feux d'hiver
choristes hommes ou femmes ainsi qu les
maquiller vous avez des niveaux qui part
du ca paix au brevet professionnel
certains anciens élèves y prennent même
goût et reviennent chaque année comme
anaïs qui s'occupe du chignon de marie
hopper l'interprète de eliza doolittle
c'est du bon stress c'est en fait il ya
peut-être aussi qui est capable de tout
ce qu'on a fait on fait plein turc donc
on a tous les solis on a aussi tout ce
qui est desservant tout ce qui est
choriste donc ça fait beaucoup de monde
à coiffer et en fait c'est vraiment
massa reste du gros stress c'est la
bonne a dream à vous en faites
mais il faut être passionné parce que
sinon après ce n'est pas supportable
le résultat est là dans les coulisses et
sur la scène tout est réglé au
millimètre
les tableaux se succèdent les coiffures
tiennent tout ça grâce en grande partie
au travail passionné des élèves et des
apprentis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]